Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I can't spell it right. So you just give a fake name, your cafe name, Julia. But the more you use it, the more it feels like you're in witness protection. Wait a minute. What kind of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this because you could have just made your espresso at home.
感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我总是拼不对。所以你随便报个假名字，用你常去的咖啡馆名，茱莉亚。但你用得越多，就越觉得像是在接受证人保护。等一下。茱莉亚到底喜欢哪种意式浓缩咖啡？现在改点拿铁是不是太晚了？不过，只要有一台 KitchenAid 的意式浓缩咖啡机，你根本就不会有这些烦恼，因为你在家里就能自己做咖啡。
Shop now at KitchenAid.ca. The year is 1936. In Europe, the Nazis are on the march. And in a sleepy college town in Bedford, Connecticut, a renowned archaeologist, just back from an eventful trip to Peru, receives a visit from two shadowy agents of U.S. Army intelligence. They have intercepted a mysterious message. Tannis development proceeding.
立即前往 KitchenAid.ca 选购。时间是 1936 年。在欧洲，纳粹正在四处扩张。在康涅狄格州贝德福德一个宁静的大学城里，一位刚从秘鲁的惊险旅程中归来的知名考古学家，迎来了两位美国陆军情报局神秘特工的造访。他们截获了一条神秘信息。塔尼斯开发工作正在进行中。
Acquire headpiece. Staff of Ra. And when the archaeologist hears those words, his eyes widen. The Nazis have discovered Tannis, he says. One of the possible resting places of the Lost Ark. The Ark of the Covenant. And so begins one of history's most thrilling archaeological field trips. And the name of that death-defying scholar, it is, of course, Tom Holland.
获取头饰。拉。的权杖。当这位考古学家听到这些话时，他的眼睛猛地睁大了。他说，纳粹已经发现了塔尼斯。那是失落的约柜的可能藏匿处之一。神的约柜。人类历史上最惊心动魄的考古实地考察就这样拉开了序幕。而那位无所畏惧的学者的名字，当然就是，汤姆·霍兰。
It's not Dominic. Although, Tom, you're a bit more of a Marcus Brody than an Indiana Jones, aren't you? I'm completely Marcus Brody. You remember the bit in Indiana Jones and the Last Crusade where Indiana Jones, he speaks 30 languages. He's at home with peoples across entire continents and he's stumbling down the railway right peoples across entire continents and he's
不是多米尼克。不过，汤姆，比起印第安纳·琼斯，你其实更有点像马库斯·布罗迪，对吧？我完全就是马库斯·布罗迪。你还记得《夺宝奇兵3：圣战奇兵》里的那个桥段吗？印第安纳·琼斯会说 30 种语言。他在各大洲的各个族群中都如鱼得水，然而他却跌跌撞撞地走在火车站寻找他的眼镜，眼镜上还冒着热气什么的……不过我们应该解释一下，对吧？为了那些没看过……呃……印第安纳·琼斯系列电影的人……那么，史蒂文·斯皮尔伯格的一系列电影，哈里森·福特戴着帽子挥舞着鞭子外出，基本上就是去发现各种东西。它们是仅有的几部伟大的考古学电影，我觉得这么说很公允。而考古学家们对它们恨之入骨。他们当然恨了。因为这些电影让考古学看起来比实际情况有趣得多。他们也意识到，他们自己的职业生涯对公众来说是个巨大的失望。
stumbling down the railway station trying to find his glasses steaming up whatever but we should explain this shouldn't we for the for the people who haven't watched uh the indiana jane series so um steven spielberg series of films harrison ford in a hat with a whip going out and basically discovering stuff they're the only great films about archaeology, I think it's fair to say. And archaeologists absolutely loathe them. Of course they do. Because they make archaeology seem much more interesting than it is. And they're conscious that their own careers are a crushing disappointment to the general public.
我的意思是，他确实会定期说，无论是关于约柜、圣杯还是其他什么，那东西应该放在博物馆里。所以这大概应该能让他们表示赞同。不过，当然了，关于文物是否应该放在博物馆里的问题，现在已经成了一个比过去更具争议的话题。印第安纳·琼斯肯定会被“去殖民化”的，对吧？
I mean, he does periodically say, you know, about whether it's the Ark of the Covenant or the Holy Grail or whatever, that belongs in a museum. So that presumably should keep them on board. Although, of course, the question of whether artefacts should be in museums is now a more controversial topic than it was. Surely Indiana Jones would be decolonised, wouldn't he?
他会被看待……他会被许多后殖民时期的考古学家视为非常不受欢迎的人。好吧，所以，我的意思是，关于……呃……比如说约柜，如果它……如果它被找到了，它最终会落入……我的意思是，我的意思是，我们应该剧透一下它最终的去向吗？也许我们不应该。无论如何，约柜最终应该去哪里，这是贯穿整部电影的一个现实问题，也许现在的问题是，你知道的，假设约柜被找到了，它应该去哪里呢？我的意思是，谁会对它拥有优先权呢？
He would be regarded, he would be held in very low regard by lots of post-colonial archaeologists. Well, so, I mean, on the topic of um should for instance the ark of the covenant if it if it were to be found it ends up i mean i mean should we give a spoiler on where it ends up maybe we shouldn't anyway the question of where the ark of the covenant should end up is a live issue throughout the film and maybe the question now is you know suppose the ark of the covenant were to be found where should it go mean, who would have dibs on it?
因为正如我们今天将要探讨的那样，由于这将成为今天节目的主题，约柜的起源非常神秘且充满争议。确实如此。但在我们深入探讨约柜之前，先简单聊聊《夺宝奇兵》。所以有趣的是，我们做过一期播客，对吧？关于所罗门王的宝藏，关于 H·赖德·哈格德那种维多利亚时代帝国小说的伟大经典。从《所罗门王的宝藏》到这部电影，存在着一条非常非常明显的传承脉络，对吧？嗯，我想斯皮尔伯格会承认这一点的。我想他绝对会承认。我的意思是，他深受自己小时候看的那些冒险故事的影响。
Because the origins of the Ark of the Covenant, as we will be exploring today, because this is going to be the theme of today's episode, are very mysterious and contested. They are indeed. But just before we go into the Ark of the Covenant, just a quick word about Raiders of the Lost Ark. So the funny thing, we did a podcast, didn't we, about King Solomon's Mines, about the H. Ryder Haggard, kind of great classic of Victorian imperial fiction. And there's a very, very obvious line of descent, isn't there, from King Solomon's Mines? Well, I think Spielberg would acknowledge that. I think he absolutely would. I mean, he was very influenced by the kind of adventures that were on when he was a boy.
而它们反过来又明显受到了赖德·哈格德的影响。嗯，是乔治·卢卡斯想出了这个点子，而且……呃……这其实和《星球大战》完全一样，他在 20 世纪 70 年代——水门事件时期（我们也做过一期关于水门事件的播客），以及美国从越南撤军时期（我们也做过一期关于这个的播客）——卢卡斯和斯皮尔伯格，这些有点那种……你知道的，书呆子气的郊区年轻人，对他们在 20 世纪 30 年代和 40 年代还是小男孩时看过的电影连续剧怀有深深的怀旧之情，他们想要重拍这些片子。下巴坚毅、黑白分明、挥舞着牛鞭的英雄。完全正确。而写剧本的人，劳伦斯·卡斯丹，他说他之所以爱上电影，是因为他看过了《阿拉伯的劳伦斯》，这当然是另一个关于某种英国帝国英雄的故事。但向他建议约柜这个点子的人是他的朋友菲利普·考夫曼，他曾在芝加哥大学学习历史。
And they, in turn, were very overtly influenced by Ryder Haggard. Well, it's George Lucas who came up with the idea and um it's exactly the same as with star wars actually that he in the 1970s the period of watergate which we've also done a podcast on and the american retreat from vietnam which we've also done a podcast on lucas and spielberg who are these sort of you know nerdy suburban young, have this sort of deep nostalgia for the film serials that they'd watched as boys in the 1930s and 1940s, and they want to remake them. Square-jawed, clear-cut, bullwhip-carrying heroes. Exactly. And the guy who wrote it, Lawrence Kasdan, he said he had fallen in love with cinema because he'd seen Lawrence of Arabia, which of course is another story of a sort of British imperial hero. But the guy who suggested to him about the Ark of the Covenant was his friend, Philip Kaufman, who had studied history at Chicago.
但你看到这个细节了吗，汤姆？一个非同寻常的细节。菲利普·考夫曼是在 11 岁补牙时，从他的牙医那里第一次听到约柜的故事的。他当时正在补牙。我对这一点感到很惊讶，因为……菲利普·考夫曼是在 11 岁补牙时，从他的牙医那里第一次听到约柜的故事的。他当时正在补牙。我对这一点感到很惊讶，因为菲利普·考夫曼是犹太人。
But have you seen this detail, Tom? An extraordinary detail. Philip Kaufman had first heard the story of the Ark of the Covenant from his dentist when he was 11. He was having some fillings. I'm surprised about that because Philip Kaufman had first heard the story of the Ark of the Covenant from his dentist when he was 11. He was having some fillings. I'm surprised about that because Philip Kaufman was Jewish. Yeah, but how many eight, nine, ten-year-olds are even listening when they're taken to the synagogue or indeed church or the mosque or whatever? They're probably half asleep. Philip Kaufman. But when you're in the dentist's chair, Tom, there's no escape. Then you're powerless.
对，但有多少八、九、十岁的孩子在被带去犹太会堂、教堂、清真寺或其他地方时会认真听呢？他们可能都在半梦半醒之间。菲利普·考夫曼。但当你坐在牙医的椅子上时，汤姆，你无处可逃。那时你是毫无反抗之力的。
You're powerless. Yeah. I disagree about that because I think that actually, I mean, there's a great sequence in Raiders of the Lost Ark where Indiana Jones is explicating what the Ark of the Covenant is. So the sinister agents, the American agents you've turned up, who you talked about in your introduction, they're asking, you know, what is the Ark of the Covenant? And Indiana Jones says, well, it's the chest that holds the Ten Commandments. The Ten Commandments, yes, the actual Ten Commandments, the original stone tablets that Moses brought down out of Mount Horeb and smashed, if you believe in that sort of thing. Didn't you guys ever go to Sunday school? Look, the Hebrews took the broken pieces and put them into the ark. When they settled in Canaan,
你毫无反抗之力。是的。我对这一点有不同看法，因为我认为，实际上，我的意思是，《夺宝奇兵》里有一个非常精彩的桥段，印第安纳·琼斯在阐述约柜到底是什么。所以那些阴险的特工，也就是你在导言中提到出现的美国特工，他们问，你知道的，约柜到底是什么？印第安纳·琼斯说，嗯，它就是存放十诫的箱子。十诫，是的，真正的十诫，就是摩西从何烈山带下来却被他砸碎的那两块最初的石板，如果你相信那种说法的话。难道你们都没去过主日学校吗？听着，希伯来人把破碎的碎片收集起来放进了约柜里。当他们在迦南定居时，
they put the ark in a place called the Temple of Solomon, where it stayed for many years, till all of a sudden, whoosh, it was gone. I mean, there's quite a lot of detail in that that is wrong. but the basic outline is right and he i remember they have a brilliant illustration kind of line drawing of the ark on a hill surrounded by a blaze of light um and it looks like a kind of weapon of mass destruction and that's the role that it is playing in raids of the lost ark you know we did an episode on oppenheimer i mean i don't want to go too studio for this, but I think part of what the story is about is, it's a kind of parable about the race for the atom bomb, isn't it?
他们把约柜放在一个叫所罗门圣殿的地方，它在那里待了很多年，直到突然间，呼的一下，它就消失了。我的意思是，其中有相当多的细节是错误的。但基本轮廓是对的。而且我记得他们有一个极好的插图——约柜在一座小山上的一幅线描画，周围环绕着耀眼的光芒……它看起来像是一种大规模杀伤性武器，而这正是它在《夺宝奇兵》中所扮演的角色。你知道，我们做过一期关于奥本海默的节目，我的意思是，我不想把这话说得太深奥，但我想这个故事的部分内涵在于，它其实是对制造原子弹竞赛的一种寓言，不是吗？
I was about to say the race for the ultimate weapon. Yeah, the idea that the Nazis are trying to get... Well, we know that then... I mean, we did our podcasts about the rise of the Nazis. There was always an element in Nazism that was fascinated by the occult and by weird esoteric theories, wasn't it? The sort of Himmler, Atlantis, all that business. And what Raiders of the Lost Ark and later on Indiana Jones and the Last Crusade capture is a combination of that, our fascination with that, but also, as you say, the real life race between Nazi and American scientists to build the world's first atom bomb for the ultimate weapon that will win the war. But of course, there is a slight tension there because of course,
我正要说这是一场关于终极武器的竞赛。对，纳粹试图获得……嗯，我们知道后来……我的意思是，我们做过关于纳粹崛起的播客。纳粹主义中一直有一种元素，对神秘学和各种怪异的深奥理论着迷，对吧？那种希姆莱、亚特兰蒂斯之类的一套。而《夺宝奇兵》以及后来的《夺宝奇兵3：圣战奇兵》所捕捉到的，正是这种元素的结合——我们对这些东西的迷恋，但正如你所说，也是纳粹科学家和美国科学家之间为制造世界上第一颗原子弹、打造赢得战争的终极武器而进行的现实生活中的竞赛。不过，当然了，这里面存在一点紧张关系，因为当然了，
it's fine for the Nazis to look for Atlantis and to cast the Atlanteans, for instance, as being Aryan. But the whole point of the Ark of the Covenant is that it is very, very Jewish. And when there is a point where one of the Nazi officers says, I feel a bit uncomfortable about this, it's all a bit Jewish for me. But conversely, for the film to work, it has to be true. I mean, the Ark of the Covenant really has to be what the Bible says it is. This kind of immense repository of power, this interface between God and man. Because if it's not true, if it's not what the Bible claims it is then its value as a weapon is nothing yeah fair enough tom i know you're going to talk a great with great enthusiasm i was about to say great length which sounds forbidding but actually it's better to say it will be so enthusiastic people won't notice how long it is but before you do that i will say one last thing about raiders of the lost ark which is is underappreciated as a british film because it was made at elstree as was star wars and it was shot i was, I always find it really weird when you read these things about
纳粹去寻找亚特兰蒂斯，并把亚特兰蒂斯人描绘成雅利安人，这没什么问题。但约柜的核心意义在于它是非常非常犹太化的。而片中有一个情节，其中一个纳粹军官说：“我对这个感觉有点不舒服，对我来说这太犹太化了。”但反过来，为了让电影成立，它必须是真的。我的意思是，约柜必须真正是圣经中所说的那样。这种巨大的力量库，神与人之间的界面。因为如果这不是真的，如果它不是圣经所声称的那样，那么它作为武器的价值就荡然无存了。好吧，有道理，汤姆。我知道你会带着巨大的热情去谈论……我本想说“长篇大论”，这听起来让人望而生畏，但实际上更好的是说你会如此热情，以至于人们不会注意到它有多长。但在你这么做之前，我要对《夺宝奇兵》说最后一句话，那就是它作为一部英国电影被低估了，因为它是在埃尔斯特里制片厂拍摄的，就像《星球大战》一样，而且它是在……
when films were actually made. So it was shot in the summer of 1980. So the headlines are full of West Ham winning the FA Cup, Mrs. Thatcher's economic experiment going hideously wrong in the summer of 1980, and lots of people being out of work. And meanwhile, these people trudging to the sound studios there to make this film about the Ark of the Covenant. But quite a 1930s vibe there. There is quite a 1930s vibe, yeah. Not wholly wrong. Anyway, that's my last attempt to anchor us in the 1980s
我每次读到关于电影实际拍摄时间的资料时，都觉得非常奇怪。它是 1980 年夏天拍摄的。所以当时头条新闻全都是西汉姆联队赢得足总杯，撒切尔夫人的经济实验在 1980 年夏天惨遭滑铁卢，还有大量的人失业。与此同时，这些人却艰难地前往那里的录音棚去拍摄这部关于约柜的电影。不过那里确实有一种 20 世纪 30 年代的气氛。确实有一种 20 世纪 30 年代的气氛，是的。并非完全不对。不管怎样，这是我最后一次试图把我们的思绪锚定在 20 世纪 80 年代，
because I know you want to take us right back to prehistory and to the biblical origins of the Ark of the Covenant. Well, I mean, just to reiterate, the Ark of the Covenant has to, I mean, the reason that Kaufman comes up with it is that they need a MacGuffin, don't they? They need something that Indiana Jones is going after. But by making it the Ark of the Covenant, they amplify the stakes massively because the Ark of the Covenant is the embodiment of the power of God on the face of earth, according to the Bible. And so if you take that seriously, then you take the plot of the film seriously. So most people probably, when they think of a biblical ark, will think of Noah's ark. That's not the ark that Indiana Jones is after, because that would be far too big to hide. Everybody at school, when I was at school, thought it was a film about Noah's ark.
因为我知道你想把我们直接带回史前时期以及约柜的圣经起源。好吧，我的意思是，重申一下，约柜必须……我的意思是，考夫曼之所以想出这个点子，是因为他们需要一个麦格芬（剧情道具），对吧？他们需要一个让印第安纳·琼斯去追寻的目标。但通过把它设定为约柜，他们极大地提高了赌注，因为根据圣经，约柜是上帝在地球表面力量的化身。所以如果你认真对待这一点，你就会认真对待电影的剧情。因此，大多数人在想到圣经中的约柜时，可能会想到诺亚方舟。那可不是印第安纳·琼斯寻找的约柜，因为那个太大了，根本藏不住。我上学的时候，学校里的每个人都以为这是一部关于诺亚方舟的电影。
But they kind of share a similar derivation, because an ark basically is a box or a chest. And it's conventionally called the Ark of the Covenant, but it has many names in the Bible. various narratives that have been stitched together to provide a kind of coherent narrative account of, right from the beginning, from creation of the world, the slavery of the chosen people in Egypt. Moses leads them out of Egypt, and he goes to Mount Sinai, and he meets with God, and God gives him various commandments that they have to follow. And this is where the Ark of the Covenant comes in. And the weird thing about it is that it is simultaneously the most important kind of object in the universe, perhaps, while also being really a very invisible presence in
但它们在词源上有相似的派生，因为方舟基本上就是一个盒子或箱子。人们习惯称它为约柜，但在圣经中它有很多名字。各种叙事被拼凑在一起，提供了一种连贯的叙事记录，从一开始世界的创造，到上帝的选民在埃及为奴。摩西带领他们离开埃及，他来到西奈山，在那里与上帝相见，上帝给了他必须遵守的各种诫命。这就是约柜登场的地方。而奇怪的是，它既是宇宙中最重要的一种物品，可能也是圣经中最不引人注目的一种存在。
the Bible. Considering how important it is, you'd expect it to be kind of popping up all over the place, but it doesn't. It kind of comes in and out. And I think that that reflects the fact that there are all these kind of various traditions, these various different accounts of what it is. So basically, I think you can distinguish three separate traditions explicating what the Ark is within the fabric of what Christians call the Old Testament, Jews call the Tanakh. So in one tradition, it's the Ark that is made by Moses in obedience to instructions given by God.
考虑到它有多么重要，你可能会期待它到处出现，但它并没有。它总是若隐若现。我认为这反映了这样一个事实：存在着各种各样的传统，关于它到底是什么，有着各种不同的说法。所以基本上，我认为在基督徒所称的旧约、犹太人所称的塔纳赫的结构中，可以区分出三种不同的传统来阐述约柜是什么。在其中一种传统中，它是摩西根据上帝给出的指示制作的方舟。
And it's the place where God meets with man. And therefore it is terrifying because it is imbued with the power of God. And to approach it is potentially lethal. So the ark bestows life, but it also bestows death. So, for example, if you were to open it and look on it tom your face might melt exactly your your eyes might kind of turn and drop out of your eye sockets and all that kind of thing yes terrifying things there's then um a much less exciting tradition which would have made this lost ark certainly a lot less dramatic which is that it's
它是上帝与人相会的地方。因此它是令人畏惧的，因为它浸透了上帝的力量。接近它可能会致命。所以方舟赐予生命，但它也带来死亡。比如，如果你打开它看着它，汤姆，你的脸可能会融化。完全正确，你的眼睛可能会扭转并从眼窝里掉出来之类的事情，是的，太可怕了。然后呢，有一个远不那么令人兴奋的传统——这个传统肯定会让这个失落的约柜戏剧性大打折扣——那就是它
basically just a kind of box to keep the tablets of the law in. So it's kind of a filing cabinet. So it's basically like the box. You've got a box where you keep your old coins. It's a bit like that. A little bit like that. Yeah. I mean, which an archaeologist I think would love, but Harrison Ford would have no interest in that. And then there's this sense of it, which again is really the one that you get in the Raiders of the Lost Ark, which is that it is a weapon of mass destruction. It's the atom bomb. It's something that destroys the enemies of the children of Israel. So basically the Ark that we see in the Raiders of the Lost Ark is the
基本上只是一个用来存放律法石板的盒子。所以它有点像个档案柜。基本上就像个盒子。你有一个用来装旧硬币的盒子。有点像那个。确实有点像。我的意思是，考古学家可能会喜欢这个，但哈里森·福特对此绝对毫无兴趣。然后还有另一种对它的理解，这正是你在《夺宝奇兵》中看到的，即它是一种大规模杀伤性武器。它是原子弹。它是能够摧毁以色列人敌人的东西。所以基本上我们在《夺宝奇兵》中看到的约柜就是
Ark that we get in the book of Exodus, which also includes the account of how the children of Israel leave Egypt, the plagues and crossing the Red Sea, and all that kind of stuff. So in Exodus, we have very precise descriptions. It's about four foot long. It's two and a half feet tall, two and a half feet wide. It's overlaid with gold. You have kind of gold rings on all the four corners so that you can put poles through it and carry it that way. And on the top, you have a great thick slab of gold, which is called the mercy seat. And this slab of gold is topped by two cherubim who are kind of facing each other. And there's
我们在《出埃及记》中看到的约柜，其中还记录了以色列人如何离开埃及、十灾以及红海分开等种种事情。所以在《出埃及记》中，我们有非常精确的描述。它大约四英尺长，两英尺半高，两英尺半宽。上面覆满了黄金。四个角上都有金环，这样就可以穿过杠杆来抬着它。而在顶部，有一块厚厚的大金板，被称为施恩座。这块金板的顶部有两个基路伯天使，它们面对面站着，中间
kind of emptiness between the cherubim and the cherubim. I mean, people have heard of cherubs, kind of rosy cheek little babies, but in the Bible, they are not that at all. They are very terrifying angels. They're the angels basically who, who kind of directly attend God. So they are, there are later descriptions of them in the Bible. They're, they're kind of winged forehead, four faced sphinxes. So mean alarming things yeah and that gap between the two faces of the cherubim is where the presence of god is it's where his in in the bible it's described as his heavy light his glory his kind of imminence um and it contains the um the two stone tablets on which the ten commandments are written and it's a very very odd thing even by the standards of the bible because god of course does appear to to people in the Bible. He appears to Adam walking in the Garden of Eden. He appears to Moses in a bush.
基路伯与基路伯之间是一个空隙。我的意思是，人们都听说过基路伯，那种脸颊红润的小胖娃娃，但在圣经里，它们根本不是那样的。它们是非常可怕的天使。它们基本上是直接侍奉上帝的天使。圣经对它们有更晚的描述。它们是那种有翅膀、有额头、有四张脸的人面狮身怪物。我的意思是，非常吓人，是的。而基路伯两面之间的那个空隙就是上帝同在的地方，在圣经中，它被描述为他沉重的光芒、他的荣耀、他的一种神圣显现。里面装着写有十诫的两块石板。即使按照圣经的标准，这也是一件非常非常古怪的事情，因为上帝当然会在圣经中向人们显现。他向在伊甸园里漫步的亚当显现。他在荆棘中向摩西显现。
He appears in a whirlwind to Job. But it's only on this kind of the mercy seat of the ark, this space between the two cherubim on the top of the ark that he is kind of routinely manifest and this this ark is exactly the ark but that occurred that you see in raids of the lost ark right the gold slab the cherubim i mean it's pretty much identical to the i think it's a little bit bigger in the film but that's always the way hollywood isn't it yeah of course of course of course um and this ark is built at the foot of mount sinai, where all the children of Israel have gathered. And Moses has gone up onto Mount Sinai and he's spoken face to face with God. He comes down with the tablets of stone. He finds that the children of Israel have got so nervous
他在旋风中向约伯显现。但唯独在这个约柜的施恩座上，在约柜顶端两个基路伯之间的这个空间里，他是以这种例行的方式显现的。而这个约柜正是你在《夺宝奇兵》中看到的那个约柜，对吧？金色的石板，基路伯天使……我的意思是，它和……我觉得电影里的稍微大了一点，但好莱坞不总是这样吗？是的，当然，当然，当然。而这个约柜是在西奈山脚下建造的，当时所有的以色列人都聚集在那里。摩西上了西奈山，与上帝面对面交谈。他带着石板下山，发现以色列人已经焦虑得
that they fall into worshipping a golden calf. Moses loses it, smashes the tablets. There's kind of chaos and disaster. God is threatening to wipe the children of Israel out. Moses goes back up to Mount Sinai, faces God, says, you know, please don't, please don't kill them all. And God kind of calms down and hands over a duplicate of the original tablets of stone. He's got a hell of a lot of tablets up there, Tom. Well, he's God. I mean, he can come up with what he likes.
开始崇拜金牛犊。摩西大发雷霆，把石板砸碎了。现场一片混乱和灾难。上帝威胁要消灭以色列人。摩西再次回到西奈山，面对上帝，说，你知道的，求求你，求求你不要杀光他们。上帝稍微冷静下来，交出了一份原本石板的复制品。他在上面有数不清的石板，汤姆。好吧，他是上帝。我的意思是，他想弄出什么就能弄出什么。
So meanwhile, down on the plain, the children of Israel have been given very precise instructions on how to build a tent that is called the tabernacle. And it's kind of like Ikea cubed. It's incredibly complicated. The instructions are very, very precise. You don't often think of Dutch theologians perhaps as being witty, but there was one called Herman Vitsius in 1872, who amusingly said that God created the whole world in six days, but he used 40 to instruct Moses about the tabernacle. Everything about it has to be completely precise. And the Ark is kept in the tabernacle in a kind of backspace, which comes to be called the Holy of Holies. Only Moses can go in there. And this is because it is incredibly dangerous. It's like going into the core of a nuclear reactor. Basically, if you touch it, you'll be struck dead. You have to follow these rules. It's like kind of very intense health and safety rules. So Moses' brother Aaron, he becomes, these are the ancestors of the priests who will tend to the tabernacle and the Ark of the Covenant.
与此同时，在平原上，以色列人得到了关于如何建造一个被称为“会幕”的帐篷的极其精确的指示。它有点像是立体的宜家。极其复杂。指示非常非常精确。你可能不会认为荷兰神学家会很幽默，但在 1872 年，有一位名叫赫尔曼·维齐乌斯的学者趣称，上帝用六天创造了整个世界，但他却花了 40 天来指导摩西关于会幕的事。关于它的每一件事都必须完全精确。约柜被保存在会幕后方的空间里，这个空间后来被称为至圣所。只有摩西才能进去。这是因为里面极其危险。就像进入核反应堆的核心一样。基本上，如果你碰它，你就会暴毙。你必须遵守这些规则。这就像是非常严格的健康与安全规则。所以摩西的哥哥亚伦，他成为了……这些就是将要照看会幕和约柜的祭司们的祖先。
But even two sons of Aaron, they make offerings to the Ark and they get struck down. And so there's a sense, which of course is absolutely manifest throughout Raiders of the Lost Ark, that the Ark is so holy that if you approach it in the wrong way, it will kill you. But also, even as you have all these very precise laws detailing how people are to approach it or not approach it, there is also a sense that the Ark has a will of its own. So in the account of the children of Israel leave the foothills of Sinai and start wandering in the desert. And there's a sense that the Ark of the Covenant is kind of free floating in front of them. They have to follow where it leads. So even though you have these poles in it for carrying it, there is also a sense that
但即使是亚伦的两个儿子，他们向约柜献祭时也被击杀了。因此有一种感觉——这在整个《夺宝奇兵》中当然显露无遗——约柜是如此神圣，如果你用错误的方式接近它，它就会杀死你。但同时，尽管有所有这些详细规定人们如何接近或不得接近它的精确法律，人们也感觉到约柜拥有它自己的意志。所以在以色列人离开西奈山麓开始在沙漠中流浪的记载中。人们感觉到约柜仿佛在他们前方自由漂浮。他们必须跟随它的引领。所以即使上面有穿杠用来抬它的杠，人们也有一种感觉，
you don't actually need it because it will move of its own volition. That's its kind of, I was going to say demonic, which is the wrong word. It's sort of divine power, isn't it? And actually, just as you're talking about it having a will of its own, do you know what it reminds me of, actually? Another device we've talked about in the rest of history that sort of stood in for the nuclear bomb, Tolkien's ring. So Tolkien's ring has this incredible power,
你其实并不需要它，因为它是凭自己的意志移动的。这就是它的一种……我本想说“恶魔般的”，这个词用错了。这是它的一种神圣力量，对吧？事实上，正当你谈到它拥有自己的意志时，你知道这让我想起了什么吗？我们在《The Rest Is History》中讨论过的另一个象征着核弹的装置——托尔金的魔戒。所以托尔金的魔戒拥有这种不可思议的力量，
but also has a will of its own and can move sometimes, or fate can take it in funny directions. Except that the ring is evil, whereas the Ark absolutely isn't. The Ark is the manifestation of God on Earth, and that's what gives it its charge. I talked about these different traditions. There's a further contradiction that you may have been wondering about, which is that if people can't approach it, then why are there rings to put poles in so that people can carry it? Because there's an inherent contradiction there. But the Bible is full of contradictions like this that aren't resolved.
但它也有自己的意志，有时会自己移动，或者命运会把它带向奇怪的方向。只不过魔戒是邪恶的，而约柜绝对不是。约柜是上帝在地球上的显现，正是这一点赋予了它力量。我刚才谈到了这些不同的传统。可能还有一个你一直在纳闷的进一步矛盾，那就是如果人们不能接近它，为什么还要有用来穿杠的环好让人抬着它呢？因为这里面存在着内在的矛盾。但圣经中充满了这种没有得到解决的矛盾。
And therefore, in a sense, I think, kind of compound the sense of mystery that surrounds it, makes it seem even more an awesome thing. So when the children of Israel arrive at the banks of the River Jordan, and they've got to cross the Jordan to get into the promised land. Canaan. They've been promised Canaan by God, which is full of great cities that have to be conquered. Here, there's no kind of hiding the ark away inside the tabernacle. You have people carrying it. They're not struck down. The ark leads the children of Israel across the River Jordan. As the people who are carrying the ark step into the river, the waters run dry and they can cross the river, the whole army, without their feet getting wet. Famously, the first city that they confront is Jericho. And the Ark is taken seven times
因此，从某种意义上说，我认为这加剧了围绕它的神秘感，使它显得更加令人敬畏。所以当以色列人到达约旦河岸时，他们必须穿过约旦河才能进入应许之地——迦南。上帝已经向他们许诺了迦南，那里到处都是需要被征服的伟大城市。在这里，没有任何把约柜藏在会幕里的说法。有人抬着它。他们没有被击杀。约柜引领以色列人穿过约旦河。当抬着约柜的人踏入河中时，河水干涸了，整支军队都可以过河，而脚鞋不湿。众所周知，他们面对的第一座城市是耶利哥。约柜被带着绕
around the walls of Jericho. Then the trumpets are blown and the walls of Jericho come tumbling down. And this is what the Nazis want the Ark for, this kind of power, this ability to destroy cities. So everybody remembers the trumpets. Well, at least I remember the trumpets, but I'd forgotten this stuff about the Ark. So it's actually the Ark. The Ark is the key thing. The Ark, not the trumpets. Yeah. Yeah. The Ark is the key thing. It's no wonder the Nazis were after it. The Ark plays the key role, basically, in the ability of the children of Israel to conquer Canaan.
耶利哥城墙走了七圈。然后号角吹响，耶利哥的城墙轰然倒塌。这正是纳粹想要约柜的原因，这种力量，摧毁城市的能力。所以每个人都记得号角。好吧，至少我记得号角，但我把关于约柜的事给忘了。所以实际上是约柜。约柜才是关键所在。约柜，而不是号角。对。对。约柜是关键所在。难怪纳粹在寻找它。约柜在以色列人征服迦南的能力中扮演了核心角色。
And the children of Israel establish themselves in Canaan. They are then kind of governed by people called judges. Call them judges gives slightly the wrong sense. You have a sense of people, you know, someone in a wig sending someone down for two years for shoplifting or something. That's not quite what they're much more kind of impressive, intimidating figures. But the weird thing is, is that throughout the book of Judges,
以色列人在迦南建立了自己的势力。他们随后由被称为“士师”的人统治。管他们叫“士师”有点词不达意。你会觉得是一群人，你知道的，某个戴假发的人判处某人两年监禁，因为他们顺手牵羊什么的。这可不太对，他们更像是那种令人印象深刻、令人生畏的人物。但奇怪的是，在整卷《士师记》中，
which describes this period, there is no account of the Ark at all. It's as though it's vanished. My favourite book of the Bible, Tom. The book of Judges. Did a project on it when I was about 12 because it's got a lot of battles. Yeah. And there's a bloke who's enormously fat
这段时期毫无关于约柜的记载。它就像是凭空消失了一样。我最喜欢的圣经书卷，汤姆。《士师记》。我大概 12 岁的时候做过一个关于它的项目，因为里面有很多战斗。对。还有一个胖得离谱的家伙，
who gets stabbed with a dagger and the folds of fat envelop it right the way up to the head. That's right. I of battles. Yeah, and there's a bloke who's enormously fat who gets stabbed with a dagger. And the folds of fat envelop it right the way up to the head. That's right. I remember that. So what I like about judges is there's less religion and more fighting. And that's what I liked as an 11-year-old. Anyway, that's a massive... I shouldn't have taken you down that tangent.
被人用匕首刺中，那一层层的脂肪把匕首一直包裹到了刀柄。没错。我记得。所以我喜欢《士师记》的原因是宗教内容少，打斗场面多。这正是我 11 岁时所喜欢的。不管怎样，这是一个巨大的……我不该带你扯到这个题外话上去。
No, not at all. But of course, you know what I'm going to say. There's no distinction between religion and fighting. Right, okay. That Church of England should absolutely'm going to say, there's no distinction between religion and fighting. Right, okay. That Church of England should absolutely hire you to make that point to young people. But of course, the paradigmatic enemies of the children of Israel, the people who are always remembered as their great enemies, are the Philistines. Sea peoples, maybe even perhaps Mycenaean Greeks who settle in the lowlands in Gaza. And the Israelites are up on the hills and there's kind of grumbling war between them.
不，完全没有。但当然，你知道我要说什么。宗教和战斗之间是没有区别的。好吧，好吧。英国圣公会绝对应该雇你向年轻人阐明这一点。但当然，以色列人典型的敌人——那些一直被人们铭记的伟大敌人——就是非利士人。海上民族，甚至可能是定居在加沙低地的迈锡尼希腊人。以色列人住在山上，双方之间有着断断续续的战争。
And in the biblical accounts of these conflicts, the Ark makes a spectacular reappearance. And having said that none of the judges really have anything to do with the Ark, in the account of the war with the Philistines, a judge appears who does have lots to do with the Ark. This is a guy called Eli. He has two sons with the tremendous names of Hophni and Phinehas. They behave very badly. They're not good people. Because of this, when they suggest taking the Ark into war against the Philistines,
而在这些冲突的圣经记载中，约柜惊艳地再次登场了。既然说士师们都跟约柜没什么关系，但在与非利士人战争的记载中，出现了一位确实跟约柜有很大关系的士师。这个人叫以利。他有两个儿子，有着极好的名字：何弗尼和非尼哈。他们表现得很糟糕。他们不是好人。正因为如此，当他们建议把约柜带到与非利士人的战场上去时，
they are not worthy to be handling it. They don't have the requisite degree of holiness. So they take the Ark into battle against the Philistines. Because God wants to make a point that Hophni and Phinehas are not up to the grade, the Israelites lose and the Ark is captured. This is obviously a tremendous debacle. Yeah, that's a disaster. And so the news is brought to Eli and he's so appalled that he drops down dead with the shock. I'm not surprised. So Dominic, you didn't do a project on this?
他们根本不配处理它。他们不具备应有的神圣程度。所以他们把约柜带上了与非利士人作战的战场。因为上帝想要表明何弗尼和非尼哈不够资格，以色列人战败了，约柜被夺走了。这显然是一场巨大的惨败。对，那是一场灾难。于是消息传到了以利那里，他震惊得当场倒地身亡。我一点也不觉得奇怪。所以，多米尼克，你没做过这方面的项目吗？
No, there was a guy beginning with Jay, who's a famous judge, Jephthah, fighting the Ammonites. So I was very big on Jephthah fighting the Ammonites and Gideon. Well, my favourite biblical people were the Ammonites, because I imagined them as Mesozoic. Walking fossils. Yeah, with their tentacles sticking out, invading Canaan. Anyway, listen, let's get back to the Philistines who've captured the Ark.
没有，有个名字以 J 开头的著名士师，叫耶弗他，在跟亚扪人打仗。所以我对耶弗他和亚扪人打仗以及基甸非常了解。好吧，我最喜欢的圣经人物是亚扪人，因为我把他们想象成中生代的步行化石。对，带着伸出来的触角，入侵迦南。不管怎样，听着，让我们回到夺走了约柜的非利士人身上。
Yeah. And so what they do is they take it to the temple of Dagon in a city called Ashdod. And Dagon is a kind of corn god, massive great statue. And they put the Ark of the Covenant in front of the Statue of Dagon. And when they come in in the morning, they find that the Statue of Dagon has teetered over and is prostrating itself before the Ark. So they put it back up again. And the next day, they come in. And this time, not only has the statue of Dagon fallen over in worship before the Ark, but it's shattered into tiny pieces. Power of the Ark. Yeah, very bad news.
对。所以他们做的是把它带到阿什多德市的大衮神庙里。大衮是一种玉米神，巨大的神像。他们把约柜放在了大衮神像的前面。当他们早上走进去时，他们发现大衮神像已经倾倒，正俯伏在约柜前。于是他们把它扶起来。第二天，他们走进去。这一次，不仅大衮神像在约柜前倒地崇拜，而且它还碎成了无数小块。约柜的力量。对，大消息。
So they move it. They move it to another town. Terrible things happen. The Philistines get afflicted by mice, which I think is not the most terrifying of plagues. That's a humdrum detail. And this is the thing that I always remember from reading about the Ark of the Covenant when I was a boy. They get afflicted by tumors. And I remember reading a book in which it was about the way that flying saucers had intervened in biblical history.
所以他们把它转移了。他们把它转移到另一个城镇。可怕的事情发生了。非利士人遭受了老鼠的灾难，我认为这并不是最可怕的灾难。这是一个平淡无奇的细节。而正是我小时候读到约柜时一直记住的事情。他们长了肿瘤。我记得读过一本书，里面讲的是飞碟如何干预圣经历史。
And this was offered as conclusive proof that the Ark of the Covenant was radioactive. I was about to say, this is radioactivity. This is a nuclear bomb thing. Well, I'm surprised they didn't bring it up actually in the Raiders of the Covenant was radioactive. I was about to say, this is radioactivity. This is a nuclear bomb thing. Well, I'm surprised they didn't bring it up, actually, in the Raiders of the Lost Ark. Yeah. Surely Graham Hancock is all over this, Tom. Well, we'll come to Graham Hancock in the second half.
而这被作为约柜具有放射性的决定性证明。我正要说，这就是放射性。这就是核弹的事。好吧，我很惊讶他们竟然没有在《夺宝奇兵》里提到这一点。对啊。汉考克（Graham Hancock）肯定对这个深信不疑，汤姆？好吧，我们会在下半场讨论格雷厄姆·汉考克。
So basically, all these tumours, all these mice, all these statues falling over left, right, and centre, the Philistines decide that they don't want to keep the Ark. So they hand it back, and they give it to the children of Israel. And it remains dangerous even for the children of Israel. So there's this incredible verse, the Lord smote the men of Beth Shemesh because they had looked into the ark of the Lord. Even he smote of the people, 50,000 and three score and 10 men. And the people lamented because the Lord had smitten many of the people with a great slaughter. So this sense that it is perilous, this is now kind of part of the narrative again. So basically the children of Israel have this incredible thing.
所以基本上，所有的肿瘤，所有的老鼠，所有的神像左右倒塌，非利士人决定他们不想再留着约柜了。于是他们把它还了回去，交还给了以色列人。即使对以色列人来说，它依然是危险的。所以有这样一句不可思议的经文：耶和华击杀了伯示麦人，因为他们窥探了耶和华的约柜。他甚至击杀了民中五万零七十人。百姓因耶和华大大击杀他们就哀哭。所以这种它是危险的感觉，现在又成为了叙事的一部分。因此，基本上以色列人拥有了这件不可思议的物品。
They're keeping it in a tent. I think that there is a sense that maybe a tent isn't entirely where it should be kept. So the judges get replaced by kings. The most famous king, of course, is David. David is told by God because for various kind of sins that he's done, that he is not the one who is going to build the temple. But even so, David is the guy who has captured Jerusalem and makes it into his capital. And the ark is brought into Jerusalem. And David is so excited by this that he dances in front of the ark through the streets.
他们把它藏在一个帐篷里。我觉得也许帐篷并不是完全应该存放它的地方。所以士师被君王取代了。最著名的君王当然是大卫。上帝告诉大卫，由于他犯下的种种罪过，他不是那个要建造圣殿的人。即便如此，大卫还是那个攻占耶路撒冷并将其定为首都的人。约柜被迎进了耶路撒冷。大卫对此兴奋不已，以至于他在街上的约柜前跳舞。
And his wife is furious about this, maybe because he was a very bad dancer. I think she feels it's undignified. Right. Kind of like, you know, dads are dancing at weddings. Yeah. But the guy who builds the temple famously is Solomon. And so the temple is modeled on the tabernacle, but built in stone. And so you, again, you have the Holy of Holies.
他的妻子对此愤怒不已，也许是因为他舞跳得太烂了。我觉得她觉得这很不体面。没错。有点像，你知道的，老爸们在婚礼上跳舞那种感觉。但建造圣殿的著名人物是所罗门。所以圣殿是仿照会幕建造的，但用的是石头。所以你再次拥有了至圣所。
And this is where the Ark of the Covenant is put. And in the Bible, it said, it came to pass when the priests would come out of the holy place, that the cloud filled the house of the Lord. So that's what makes the temple so awe-inspiring, is that God in some way is present within this house. And it's this that so it's built on zion the mountain of god and it's this that gives to jerusalem dare i say it's sacral quality and then you have um after after the reign of solomon you have biblical accounts of all these kind of various kings the the kingdom of israel splits into two so you have kingdom of israel in the north you have the kingdom of judah in the south and the last king really who is described as having anything to do with it is a guy called hezekiah and he is the king of judah at the time when the northern kingdom of israel is destroyed
这就是安放约柜的地方。圣经中说，祭司从圣所出来的时候，有云充满耶和华的殿。这就是为什么圣殿如此令人敬畏，因为上帝以某种方式在这个殿宇中同现。正是这一点——它建在上帝的山锡安上——赋予了耶路撒冷，我敢说，神圣的品质。然后呢，在所罗门统治之后，你从圣经中读到了所有这些各种各样君王的记录，以色列王国分裂成了两个：你在北部有以色列王国，你在南部有犹大王国。而最后一个被描述为与它有任何关联的国王是一个叫希西家的家伙，当北国以色列被
by the assyrians who are this great and terrifying empire based in northern mesopotamia so they come and they destroy israel and then they come and lay siege to Jerusalem. And that siege is defeated. I mean, kind of interestingly, because a plague of mice come and gnaw away at the bowstrings of the arrows of the Assyrians. What is it with mice and the Ark of the Covenant, Tom? Mice and the Ark have some kind of strange relationship. Rats I could get. But of course, the rats don't appear in Indiana Jones, do they? That's in the Last Crusade.
以东人……哦不，是亚述人摧毁时，他是犹大国的国王。亚述人是位于美索不达米亚北部一个伟大而可怕的帝国。所以他们来摧毁了以色列，然后他们来对耶路撒冷进行围城。而那场围城战失败了。有趣的是，因为一场老鼠瘟疫来咬断了亚述人弓箭的弓弦。老鼠和约柜之间到底是怎么回事，汤姆？老鼠和约柜有着某种奇怪的关系。老鼠我还能理解。但当然，老鼠并没有出现在印第安纳·琼斯电影里，对吧？那是《圣战奇兵》。
It's snakes. So they could at least use... Snakes would be much more true to the Spielberg vision, wouldn't they? Actually, I'm approaching this the wrong way around. You are. Anyway, so listen. So let's just get to the end of the biblical account. So Hezekiah is the last figure in the Bible who's described as having seen the Ark.
那是蛇。所以他们至少可以用……蛇会更符合斯皮尔伯格的愿景，对吧？其实，我这是把顺序弄反了。你是反了。不管怎样，听着。所以让我们直接跳到圣经记载的结尾。希西金……希西家是圣经中最后一个被描述为见过约柜的人。
And then I read what Indy said, Indiana Jones said. It stayed in the Temple of Solomon for many years till all of a sudden, whoosh, it was gone. So that whoosh, it was gone. There isn't a whoosh in the Bible. It just vanishes. Was it not captured by the Babylonians? Because they captured Jerusalem. Surely they took it back to Babylon. No. Well, as far as we can tell, no, because there's actually in the second book of Kings,
然后我读到了印第安纳·琼斯说的话。它在所罗门圣殿里待了多年，直到突然间，呼的一下，它就消失了。所以那个“呼的一下，它就消失了”，圣经里可没有什么“呼的一下”。它就是凭空消失了。它不是被巴比伦人夺走了吗？因为他们占领了耶路撒冷。他们肯定把它带回巴比伦了。没有。嗯，据我们所知，没有，因为实际上在《列王纪下》里，
you get this great inventory of all the loot that is taken from the temple. And the Ark of the Covenant is notable by its absence. It's not there. And when in due course that the temple gets rebuilt
你可以看到一份从圣殿里掠夺的所有战利品的宏大清单。而约柜在其中显著缺席。它不在那里。而当这座圣殿日后被重建时
because it's been destroyed by the Babylonians, but the Babylonian exiles are allowed to come back by the Persians, but the Babylonian exiles are allowed to come back by the Persians and to rebuild it. The rabbis, looking back at this period, are confident that the Ark was not in the second temple. We can be pretty confident of this because famously, when the Romans capture Jerusalem under Pompey the Great, Pompey goes into the Holy of Holies and reports that there is nothing there.
因为圣殿被巴比伦人摧毁了，但波斯人允许巴比伦流亡者返回，波斯人允许巴比伦流亡者返回并重建圣殿。拉比们在回顾这段历史时，确信约柜并不在第二圣殿中。我们可以相当确信这一点，因为众所周知，当罗马人在庞培大帝的率领下攻占耶路撒冷时，庞培进入了至圣所，并报告说里面空无一物。
There is no Ark. And he's not struck, you know, his face doesn't melt. He's not haunted by mice, none of these things. Well, everything goes terribly for him from that point on. You know, he's had a career of unexampled success and then his career starts to tank. So, I mean, I agree. It's not like having your face melt, is it? Or be eaten by mice or get tumors, but it is a kind of judgment. Anyway, so that account, which is, we only have the Bible as evidence for what the Ark of the Covenant was. We have no other accounts of it. That leaves two massive mysteries, which perhaps we could come to in the second half. The first is, what was the Ark? Where did these traditions come from? Are they likely to be true? And the second is, where did it go?
里面没有约柜。而且你知道，他没有遭到天谴，他的脸也没有融化。他也没有被老鼠纠缠，这些事情都没有发生。好吧，从那时起，他的一切都变得糟糕透顶。你知道的，他曾有过一段前无古人的成功职业生涯，然后他的事业就开始走下坡路了。所以，我的意思是，我同意。这不像是脸融化了，对吧？或者被老鼠吃掉，或者长肿瘤，但这确实是一种审判。无论如何，这些记载——我们只有《圣经》作为证据来证明约柜是什么。我们没有关于它的其他任何记载。这留下了两个巨大的谜团，也许我们可以在下半部分讨论它们。第一个是，约柜是什么？这些传统从何而来？它们可能是真的吗？第二个是，它去哪儿了？
Where did it end up? What happened to it? Great mysteries. And we will address them, Tom. We will don our fedoras, pick up our bullwhips and address them after the break. See you then.
它最终流落何方？它发生了什么？巨大的谜团。我们会探讨这些问题的，汤姆。我们会在中场休息后戴上呢帽，拿起牛鞭，然后来探讨这些。到时候见。
Chiara, it means smart in Italian. Too bad your barista can't spell it right. So you just give a fake name, your cafe name, Julia. But the more you use it, the more it feels like you're in witness protection. Wait a minute. What kind of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this because you could have just made your espresso at home. Shop now at KitchenAid.ca. I'm Marina Hyde.
基娅拉（Chiara），在意大利语里是聪明的意思。可惜你的咖啡师拼不对。所以你只能报个假名，你的咖啡馆名字，朱莉娅。但你用的次数越多，就越觉得自已像是在接受证人保护。等一下。朱莉娅到底喜欢什么样的浓缩咖啡？现在改变拿铁订单是不是太晚了？但如果你有一台KitchenAid的浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些想法了，因为你可以直接在家里制作浓缩咖啡。立即前往KitchenAid.ca选购。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩余娱乐》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦猛料的独家来源。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，向大家讲述它的运作方式。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告的音频、独家精选节目以及提前购买现场演出门票的权限，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Indiana Jones is talking us through the Ark of the Covenant. So Indy, you ended last time by saying you would address two questions. First, what is the Ark and where does it come from? And secondly, where did it go? So let's do question one first. Where does this idea of this sort of sacred box come from, do you think? Well, basically it comes from the Bible. I mean, as I said in the end of the first half, this is our only source for it. And so like so much in the Bible, it's kind of midway between history and myth, between what becomes monotheism and a kind of the pagan world from which that monotheism emerges between Israel and the cultures in which the Israelites lived. That generates all kinds of
欢迎回到《剩余历史》。印第安纳·琼斯正在为我们讲述约柜的故事。印第，你上集结束时说你会探讨两个问题。首先，什么是约柜，它从何而来？其次，它去哪儿了？我们先来探讨第一个问题。你认为这种神圣箱子的概念是从哪里来的？嗯，基本上它来自《圣经》。我的意思是，正如我在上半部分结束时所说的那样，《圣经》是我们关于它的唯一来源。所以，就像《圣经》中的许多内容一样，它介于历史和神话之间，介于一神论的形成与一神论崛起之前的那种异教世界之间，介于以色列与以色列人生活其中的文化之间。这产生了各种各样的
paradoxes and ambiguities. I think that the reason that the Ark is such a powerful symbol within the Bible is that all those paradoxes that surround the way in which the Bible came to be written are mapped onto the paradoxical nature of the arc within the fabric of the text. If that makes sense, it's, it's the power of the, of the arc within the con within the fabric of the narrative,
悖论和模棱两可之处。我认为，约柜之所以能成为《圣经》中如此强大的象征，是因为环绕《圣经》成书方式的种种悖论，被映射到了文本结构中约柜的矛盾本质上。如果这样说得通的话，这就是……约柜的力量在……在叙事结构中的力量，
the biblical narrative owes a lot to the, the paradoxes and ambiguities of how the Bible came to be written. Right. Okay. And now here's the question. I would guess as a complete outsider and novice on all this, that there must have been other kind of cults, as it were, and other peoples in the Levant in this period who had boxes or, I don't know, thrones or sacred things. And this is one of them. So the Egyptians, for instance, they definitely have kind of sacred chests. And it's the Egyptians,
《圣经》叙事的很大一部分归功于《圣经》成书过程中的悖论和模棱两可之处。好吧。好了，现在的问题是。作为一个对外行和新手来说，我猜想在这一时期的累范特，肯定还有其他种类的崇拜，以及其他拥有箱子的人群，或者我不知道，宝座或神圣的东西。而这就是其中之一。比如埃及人，他们肯定也有某种神圣的箱子。而且正是埃及人，
of course, that the children of Israel define themselves against. So they would never acknowledge that, but perhaps that's part of it. We know that the Phoenicians, who are very important in helping Solomon build the temple, according to the biblical account, that they had chests that they carried about in chariots. So presumably they have a kind of holiness to them. So there's a wonderful new book that came out, I think, a couple of years ago called God and Anatomy by Francesca Stavrakopoulou, who's a professor of biblical studies at Exeter. And she is interested in the idea, the trace elements that you get within the biblical narratives of God as a kind of human figure, so a physical figure. So that idea of Moses going up Mount Sinai and looking in God's face, this is meant literally,
当然，以色列人是以埃及人为参照来确立自我认同的。所以他们永远不会承认这一点，但也许这也是其中一部分。我们知道，根据《圣经》记载，在帮助所罗门建造圣殿方面发挥了非常重要作用的腓尼基人，他们也有装在战车里四处运送的箱子。所以大概这些箱子对他们来说也有某种神圣性。因此，埃克塞特大学《圣经》研究教授弗兰西斯·斯塔夫拉科普洛夫（Frances Stavrakopoulou）在几年前出版了一本精彩的新书，名叫《上帝与解剖学》（God and Anatomy）。她对这样一个想法很感兴趣——你在《圣经》叙事中得到的关于上帝的痕迹，即上帝是一个类似人类的形象，也就是一个实体形象。所以摩西登上西奈山并看着上帝的脸这个想法，字面意思就是这样的，
she argues. So she argues that the ark may originally have been a footstool. It was kind of understood as being the receptacle on which God's feet rested. So I mean, that's very much a very contested perspective. But it's possible as well that that idea derives from the Egyptian tradition of placing covenants, law codes at the feet of their gods. So you're absolutely right that there are all these kinds of various traditions bubbling around. But the honest truth is that we don't know. We don't know. But certainly the Ark of the Covenant lies at the heart of something that is absolutely crucial to both Jewish and Christian understandings of their relationship to God, which is this idea
她辩称。因此她认为，约柜最初可能是一个脚凳。它在某种程度上被理解为上帝双脚放置的容器。所以，我的意思是，这在很大程度上是一个饱受争议的观点。但也有可能这个想法源于埃及传统，即把契约、法典放在他们神明的脚下。所以你完全没错，有各种各样的传统在周围涌现。但老实说，我们并不知道。我们不知道。但可以肯定的是，约柜是犹太人和基督徒理解他们与上帝关系的核心，这是绝对至关重要的，也就是这个想法——
that the tablets of stone do form a covenant, a bond between the children of Israel and God. And this in the context of antiquity is absolutely unique. Gods in the ancient world serve as witnesses to covenants. The idea that a people could have a covenant with a God is something wholly exceptional. I think that the holiness, the paradoxes, the ambiguities that hedge the Ark of the Covenant around are reflective of the almost blasphemous quality of that covenant. The idea that humans and the divine can be joined in something like that is, by the standards of the ancient Near East, very, very shocking. When you say it's a covenant, I mean, a covenant is a two-way thing. What is God promising to do?
石板确实构成了契约，构成了以色列人与上帝之间的纽带。这在古代背景下是绝无仅有的。古代世界的诸神充当契约的见证人。一个民族可以与神立约的想法是完全非同寻常的。我认为，环绕约柜的神圣性、悖论和模棱两可，反映了那种契约近乎亵渎的性质。人类和神圣事物可以这样结合在一起的想法，按照古代近东的标准来看，是非常非常令人震惊的。当你说是契约时，我的意思是，契约是双向的。上帝承诺要做什么？
What is his part of the bargain, as it were? He's going to love them and look after them and protect them. Periodically, if they break the covenant, then he will punish them. But he always does it in a kind of spirit of love. And it's the fact that it is written down, that it's a contract. Yeah, it's a contract. And so it's this idea that an all-powerful God can bind himself contractually is fundamental to the development of both Jewish and Christian theology. Because, for instance, it means that it makes it much easier for Jewish and Christian traditions to fuse with
可以说是他那部分的交易是什么？他要爱他们、照顾他们、保护他们。如果他们破坏了契约，他就会定期惩罚他们。但他总是以一种爱的精神来做这件事。关键在于它是写下来的，是一个合同。是的，是一个合同。因此，全能的上帝能够以契约的方式约束自己的这种想法，对犹太神学和基督教神学的发展都是至关重要的。因为，举例来说，这意味着它使犹太和基督教传统更容易与
the inheritance of Greek philosophy. Because philosophy essentially is an attempt to fathom the laws that govern the universe in the way that laws govern a city. So there's this idea that you have in Plato, in Aristotle, in the kind of philosophical traditions that pass into the Roman period, that it's possible to fathom the universe in terms of laws that govern it. And this is something that Jewish philosophy provides as well. So you have this guy Philo, who's an Alexandrian philosopher in the first century AD, so around the same time as St. Paul. And he's absolutely obsessed by the Ark of the Covenant as a kind of symbol of the fusion of
希腊哲学的遗产融合。因为哲学本质上是试图弄清支配宇宙的法律，就像法律支配城市一样。所以在柏拉图、亚里斯多德以及流传到罗马时期的哲学传统中，都有这样一种想法：有可能根据支配宇宙的法律来理解宇宙。这也是犹太哲学所提供的东西。所以你有一个叫斐洛（Philo）的人，他是公元一世纪的亚历山大哲学家，也就是大约和圣保罗同时代的人。他绝对痴迷于约柜，将其视为希腊传统与犹太传统融合的某种象征。
Greek and Jewish traditions. This idea that the universe can be fathomed because God has laid down laws and God himself will obey those laws. And in the long run, this is enormously, enormously influential. So I think in that sense, the Ark is a lot more than just a weird box that gets carried around in. It's genuinely powerful. I mean, it's ideologically powerful. And the power does not reside in melting people's faces so much as giving us a sense of the sacredness of the contract, right? And the idea of a covenant as by the fact that the Ark itself vanishes. So in a way, the idea of the Ark as the interface between God and man, as a kind of physical expression of this idea that God has bound himself contractually, this becomes something metaphysical rather than couched within an object. And so that then raises the question of what happened to the Ark. So there are all kinds of theories about this, and lots of these series are actually very ancient so one theory is that uh it got carted off by the egyptians right specifically a king um who in the bible is
宇宙是可以被理解的，因为上帝制定了法律，而上帝本人也会遵守这些法律。从长远来看，这是非常非常有影响力的。所以我认为从这个意义上说，约柜不仅仅是一个用来装东西的奇怪箱子。它确实具有强大的力量。我的意思是，它具有意识形态上的力量。这种力量不在于融化人们的脸，而在于让我们感受到契约的神圣性，对吧？契约的概念体现在约柜本身的消失上。因此在某种程度上，约柜作为上帝与人之间的交汇点，作为“上帝以契约方式约束自己”这一理念的物理表达，它变成了一种形而上学的东西，而不是寄托在某一个实体物体中。这就引出了一个问题：约柜究竟发生了什么？关于这一点有各种各样的理论，而且其中很多理论其实非常古老。所以其中一种理论是，它被埃及人掠走了，对吧？具体来说是一个国王，在《圣经》中
called shishak who was probably a pharaoh called sheshonk sheshonk the first tremendous name yeah um and and that of course would make it possible that the ark of the covenant that raiders of the lost ark is right atanasanas, near Cairo. So presumably that's where that theory, you know, as you said, Philip Kaufman did history at Chicago. So maybe that's what he was drawing on for that. Another is that it got removed and hidden by one of the kings of Judah before the Babylonians came to keep it for safekeeping. That it's hidden somewhere in the Holy Land. They forgot where they'd put it, basically.
被称为示撒（Shishak），他可能是一个名叫舍顺克（Sheshonk）的法老，舍顺克一世，真是个了不起的名字，对，这当然使得《夺宝奇兵》里关于约柜藏在开罗附近的塔尼斯（Tanis）的说法有可能是真的。所以大概这就是那个理论的来源，就像你说的，菲利普·考夫曼（Philip Kaufman）在芝加哥学过历史。所以也许这就是他创作的灵感来源。另一个理论是，在巴比伦人到来之前，犹太的一个国王将其移走并藏起来以妥善保管。它被藏在圣地的某个地方。基本上是他们忘了把它放在哪里了。
So somewhere, it's waiting for some archaeologists to dig it up well yes either an archaeologist or it will be revealed at the end of days i mean you can take your pick specifically the idea is that it's been hidden by an angel in a rock so that would make it a challenge even as a challenge the best archaeologist perhaps and there's a very controversial, certainly if you're Jewish, theory that was proposed by the Samaritans, who the Jews hated and feeling was entirely mutual. And they claimed that it had been hidden on Mount Gerizim, which is within the Holy Land, but is a mountain that's sacred to the Samaritans. Right. Those are kind of the various theories. However, what is the impact of the absence of the Ark of the Covenant on the way that Jews and Christians come to understand their own covenant with God? So Jews do not forget the Ark of the Covenant. this going into um into the roman period because there's a a town a frontier town called dura europos which is um it's kind of almost literally on the border between what's now syria and iraq and that was the border between the roman and the persian empires right yes and so it gets destroyed
所以它在某个地方，正等待着某个考古学家去把它挖出来。是的，要么是考古学家，要么它会在世界末日时重见天日。我的意思是，你可以任选一种。具体来说，这种说法是它被一个天使藏在了一块石头里，所以这甚至对最好的考古学家来说也是一个巨大的挑战。还有一个非常有争议的理论——如果你是犹太人的话，绝对会觉得有争议——是由撒玛利亚人提出的，犹太人恨撒玛利亚人，而且这种感觉完全是相互的。他们声称约柜被藏在基利心山（Mount Gerizim）上，这座山在圣地境内，但对撒玛利亚人来说是一座神圣的山。对。这些就是各种各样的理论。然而，约柜的缺席对犹太人和基督徒理解他们与上帝的圣约产生了什么影响呢？犹太人并没有忘记约柜。这种记忆一直延续到
by the persians in 256 ad and kind of soil and rubble falls on top of it so almost perfectly preserved and there's this incredible synagogue that's been found there that is decorated with stunning biblical scenes you know in a completely unique way because famously synagogues don't tend to be illustrated with biblical scenes but this does and it shows the ark being carried away from the temple of dagon and you've got all the kind of shattered fragments of uh of the idol of Dagon and you've got all the shattered fragments of the idol of Dagon around it. But what's interesting about the way that the Ark is portrayed in this painting is that it doesn't correspond to the description of the Ark that you get in the Bible, but rather to the image of the Ark that you get in synagogues. In this Ark, you get the sacred scrolls,
罗马时期，因为有一个边境小镇叫杜拉欧罗普斯（Dura-Europos），它几乎可以说是字面意义上位于现在的叙利亚和伊拉克边界上，也就是罗马帝国和波斯帝国之间的边界，对吧？是的，所以在公元256年，它被波斯人摧毁了，泥土和瓦砾落在了它上面，所以它几乎被完美地保存了下来。在那里发现了一个不可思议的犹太会堂，里面装饰着用完全独特的方式绘制的令人惊叹的《圣经》场景，众所周知，犹太会堂往往不会用《圣经》场景来装饰，但这个会堂却有。它展示了约柜被从大衮神庙中运走的情景，周围全是大衮偶像的破碎碎片。
the Torah scrolls, the scrolls that embody the first five books of the Bible. I think that you get a sense there that what the rabbis come to call the Shekinah, which is the presence of God in a place. Archetypally, it had been present on the lid of the Ark of the Covenant. But now that the Ark of the Covenant has gone, and obviously by the third century AD, the temple has gone as well. It's been destroyed by the Romans. Therefore, the Shekinah, the presence of God, is something that can be experienced by the Jewish people without reference to something that is physical, be it an ark or a physical building. The rabbis say that the Shekinah is present whenever someone studies Torah, whenever someone is reading these scriptures, or indeed whenever 10 people are
大衮偶像的破碎碎片散落四周。但这幅画中描绘的约柜有趣的地方在于，它并不符合《圣经》中对约柜的描述，而是符合犹太会堂里约柜的形象。在这个约柜里，装着神圣的卷轴，也就是妥拉卷轴，即体现《圣经》前五本书的卷轴。我认为你可以从那里感受到，拉比们后来称之为“舍吉拿”（Shekinah）的东西，也就是上帝在一个地方的显现。原本，它一直显现在约柜的盖子上。但现在约柜已经消失了，到了公元三世纪，圣殿显然也已经消失了。它被罗马人摧毁了。因此，“舍吉拿”（上帝的同在）变成了犹太人无需借助任何实体事物（无论是约柜还是实体建筑）就能体验到的东西。拉比们说，每当有人学习妥拉时，每当有人在阅读这些经文时，或者每当十个人
gathered together in prayer. So there's this sense that that joining of the divine with the mortal is something that has been divorced from the kind of awesome specificity that the art represented and has become something that all Jewish people can participate in. And you actually have a kind of rather similar idea in Christianity where St. Paul preaches a new covenant, a second covenant that Christ has ushered in. And that covenant is written on the heart of each individual believer, which means in turn that it's the individual Christian or indeed the assembly of all Christians, the ecclesia of the church that has become the arch. And so it's kind of been abstracted. It's become a kind of symbol. So Tom, it will amaze nobody to hear that much as I love the idea that the Ark has become this fantastically interesting symbol, I'm actually keenest to hear where it's really been hidden and has it been hidden by the Templars or whoever it might be. saying that the Shekinah can be manifest wherever 10 people gather to pray. They do also have traditions that the Ark is in Rome, that it got captured by the Romans when they sacked Jerusalem,
聚集在一起祈祷时，“舍吉拿”就在场。所以这就给人一种感觉，神圣与凡俗的结合已经脱离了约柜所代表的那种令人敬畏的具体性，变成了一种所有犹太人都可以参与的事情。基督教中其实也有一个非常相似的概念，圣保罗宣讲了一个新约，也就是基督开创的第二个约。这个契约被写在每个信徒的心里，这意味着反过来，每一个基督徒，或者说所有基督徒的集合，即教会的“埃克西亚”（ecclesia），已经成为了约柜。所以它在某种程度上被抽象化了。它变成了一种象征。所以，汤姆，听到我这么说，没有人会感到惊讶：尽管我很喜欢约柜已经成为这样一个极其有趣的象征的想法，但我其实最想知道它到底被藏在哪里了，它是被圣殿骑士团还是别的什么人藏起来的呢？他们说“舍吉拿”可以在十个人聚集祈祷的任何地方显现，他们也有传说称约柜在罗马，当罗马人洗劫耶路撒冷时，他们夺取了约柜，
they took it to Rome, and that it was kept in the Lateran Palace, which was the palace of the Pope before the Vatican. Unfortunately, this burnt down in the 14th century. One tradition says that this is when the Ark was lost. But another tradition is that it's still in the vatican to this of course it is this is the stuff i'm definitely all the rosicrucians have got it or somebody of that ilk surely but um there are there are other theories you'll be happy to know and um i think i think your wife and her sister rachel will be very excited to know that there's a tradition that links it to Ireland. They'll be delighted.
他们把它带到了罗马，并把它保存在拉特朗宫（Lateran Palace）里，那是梵蒂冈之前教皇的宫殿。不幸的是，这个宫殿在14世纪被一场大火烧毁了。一个传说称，约柜就是在那个时候丢失的。但另一个传说称，它至今仍旧在梵蒂冈。当然是的，这就是我绝对坚信的东西。玫瑰十字会肯定拥有它，或者某个类似密修会的人肯定拥有它，但是……不过还有其他理论，你们会高兴地知道，而且……我想……我想你妻子和她的姐姐雷切尔（Rachel）听到有一个传说把它和爱尔兰联系起来一定会非常兴奋。她们一定会非常高兴。
Yeah. So where is it in Ireland? Paul Rouse, I hope, would be excited by this as well. Our Irish guests. All our Irish listeners. Yeah. So you may remember in our episode on the coronation, we talked about how the stone of scone was originally the pillow, the rock on which Jacob rested his head. Yes.
是的。那么它在爱尔兰的什么地方？我希望保罗·罗斯（Paul Rouse）也会为此感到兴奋。我们爱尔兰的嘉宾。我们所有的爱尔兰听众。是的。所以你可能还记得在我们关于加冕典礼的那集里，我们谈到了斯通之石（Stone of Scone）最初是如何成为枕头的，也就是雅各（Jacob）靠过头的石头。是的。
And I absolutely believe that, by the way. And how it was brought to Ireland by an Egyptian princess. Well, there are traditions that she also brought the Ark of the Covenant. She brought two things that are really difficult to transport. Well, no, the Ark of the Covenant is a lot easier because you've got those rings and you can stick poles in it. But also it moves under the same steam, right? Well, exactly. So if you're carrying that stone of scune, you could. Yeah, you could.
顺便说一句，我绝对相信这一点。它又是如何被一位埃及公主带到爱尔兰的。好吧，有传说称她还带来了约柜。她带了两个非常难运输的东西。好吧，不，约柜要容易得多，因为你有那些环，你可以把杆子插进去。而且它也是靠同样的动力移动的，对吧？嗯，完全正确。所以如果你带着那块斯通之石，你就能。是的，你完全可以。
Yeah. I mean, maybe you could put the stone of scune inside the Ark of the Covenant. I mean, I don't know. I don't know. The traditions are obviously not entirely waterproof. And the theory is that it's brought back to the Hill of Tara, where the high kings of Ireland are proclaimed and buried there. And at the end of the 19th century, a group called the British Israelites become very, very excited about this. And the British Israelites believe that people in Britain and Ireland are descended from the
是的。我的意思是，也许你可以把斯通之石放进约柜里？我的意思是，我不知道。我不知道。这些传说显然并非完全天衣无缝。该理论认为，它被带回了塔拉山（Hill of Tara），爱尔兰至高王们在那里被宣称即位并被埋葬。在19世纪末，一个名为“英属以色列人”（British Israelites）的群体对这个说法感到非常非常兴奋。英属以色列人认为，英国和爱尔兰的人民是
lost tribes of Israel, the 10 tribes who were carried off into exile by the Assyrians when they destroyed the kingdom of Israel and vanished. Are they Jewish, the British Israelites? Well, not Jewish because the Jews are from the kingdom of Judah, but they're to be seen as Israelite, which is why they're not the British Jews, they're the British Israelites. But they're all the children of Israel, yes. And so between 1899 and 1902, they start digging it up. So they arrive at the end of time and start digging it up. And Irish nationalists get terribly upset by this. And so WB Yeats, a great poet, writes a letter of protest to the Times. But his girlfriend, well, not his girlfriend, but certainly the woman he's madly in love with, Maude Gonne,
以色列失落的十支派的后裔，这十个支派在亚述人摧毁以色列王国时被掳到流亡之地并消失了。英属以色列人是犹太人吗？嗯，不是犹太人，因为犹太人来自犹大王国，但他们被视为以色列人，这就是为什么他们不是英国犹太人，而是英属以色列人。但他们都是以色列的后裔，是的。所以在1899年到1902年间，他们开始挖掘它。所以他们在时间的尽头赶来并开始挖掘它。爱尔兰民族主义者对此感到非常愤怒。于是伟大的诗人W·B·叶芝（W.B. Yeats）给《泰晤士报》写了一封抗议信。但他的女朋友——好吧，不是他的女朋友，但绝对是他疯狂爱慕的女性——莫德·冈妮（Maude Gonne），
and is accompanied by Arthur Griffith,ith the um leader of shin fein yeah you remember the monarchist leader shin fein yeah unexpected combination austro-hungarian enthusiast yes so they um they go to tara and this great bonfire has been built there um prepared for the coronation of edward the seventh again delighted in celebration and uh maude gone and arthur griffith get there and they light the bonfire early and dance around it, singing nationalist songs and proclaiming their opposition to the British-Israelite excavations. And so the excavations get stopped.
在芬兰新芬党领袖亚瑟·格里菲斯（Arthur Griffith）的陪同下，是的，你还记得那个君主制的新芬党领袖，对吧，奥匈帝国的狂热支持者，是的，所以他们……他们去了塔拉，那里已经筑起了一座巨大的篝火，为了庆祝爱德华七世的加冕典礼而准备的。再次强调，是在庆祝中。莫德·冈妮和亚瑟·格里菲斯到达那里，提前点燃了篝火，围着它跳舞，高唱民族主义歌曲，宣称他们反对英属以色列人的考古发掘。于是发掘工作就被迫停止了。
That is a bizarre story, isn't it? Isn't it? That's so strange. It's absolutely brilliant. And a scene that we omitted from our account of irish relations tom i have to say it doesn't surprise me that i mean paul rouse was telling us wasn't either books in ireland claiming the chess is irish so it doesn't surprise me that the ark of the covenant is also irish well so it may still be there yeah but also i so i've got your notes in
这是一个离奇的故事，对吧？难道不是吗？太奇怪了。这绝对太棒了。这是我们在讲述爱尔兰关系时遗漏的一个场景，汤姆，我必须说，这并不让我感到意外。我的意思是，保罗·罗斯之前告诉过我们，爱尔兰也有书本声称约柜在爱尔兰，所以约柜也属于爱尔兰，这并不让我感到意外。好吧，所以它可能还在那里。是的。而且，我……我手里拿着你的笔记，
front of me so i know what's coming. I love this stuff about Ethiopia. Right. So Ethiopia is the best, the most extraordinary, the most credible, and certainly the most ancient of these traditions that say that the Ark got carried away from Jerusalem, carried away from the Holy Land, and is kept in a wholly different location. And the tradition is vested in this ancient text called the Kebra Nagast, the glory of the kings. And the story that it tells patently derives from biblical accounts, but gives it a kind of interesting spin. It's a kind of spinoff from the franchise.
所以我知道接下来要讲什么。我太喜欢埃塞俄比亚的这些内容了。好吧。所以埃塞俄比亚是这些传说中最好、最不可思议、最可信，当然也是最古老的传说，它们声称约柜被从耶路撒冷带走，从圣地带走，并被保存在一个完全不同的地方。这个传说记载在一本名为《王权荣耀》（Kebra Nagast）的古老文本中。它所讲述的故事明显源自《圣经》的记载，但给它赋予了一种有趣的角度。这有点像是这个系列的外传。
So Solomon builds the temple, puts the Ark of the Covenant inside the Holy of Holies at the heart of the temple. He is famously visited by the Queen of Sheba. And according to the Ethiopians, Sheba was Ethiopia. And the Queen of Sheba was called Makeda. This is very H. Ryder Haggard, Tom. And Queen Makeda, it's very, very H. Ryder Haggard. And H. Ryder Haggard absolutely is aware of these traditions and is drawing on them. Victorian venture writers are obsessed by these stories. So according to the Kebra Nagast, the Queen of Sheba, Makeda, travels to Jerusalem. She visits Solomon and she's converted to the worship of the God of Israel. She is due to go.omon who is basically a massive ledge and this is we have biblical evidence for this yeah he tricks her into sleeping with him on the night before her departure
所以所罗门建造了圣殿，把约柜放在圣殿核心的至圣所里。示巴女王（Queen of Sheba）带着盛名来拜访他。根据埃塞俄比亚人的说法，示巴就是埃塞俄比亚。而示巴女王名叫玛姬达（Makeda）。这非常像H·赖德·哈格德（H. Ryder Haggard）的风格，汤姆。玛姬达女王，这确实非常H·赖德·哈格德。而且H·赖德·哈格德绝对知道这些传统并正在借鉴它们。维多利亚时代的探险小说家对这些故事痴迷不已。所以根据《王权荣耀》，示巴女王玛姬达前往耶路撒冷。她拜访了所罗门，并皈依了对以色列上帝的崇拜。她正准备离开……所罗门基本上是个了不起的大人物，关于这一点我们有《圣经》证据支持，是的，他在她离开的前一晚诡计多端地与她同床共枕，
and gives her a ring to give to her son so that he will be able to recognize his heir and it's a bit like the legend of theseus and aegis you remember yes yeah that aegis leaves signs for theseus so that theseus can then come and find him. It's a similar kind of goings on with this. So the son of Solomon and Makeda, the queen of Sheba, he's called Manalik. And he's born in Ethiopia. He reaches manhood and he goes to Jerusalem carrying the ring that Solomon has given him. Solomon recognizes him and Solomon gives Manalik his blessing. Manalik then goes home and he goes
并送给她一枚戒指给她的儿子，这样他就能认出自己的继承人，这有点像忒修斯（Theseus）和埃勾斯（Aegeus）的传说，你还记得吗？是的，是的，埃勾斯为忒修斯留下了记号，以便忒修斯日后来找他。这里也有类似的事情发生。所以所罗门和示巴女王玛姬达的儿子名叫墨涅利克（Menelik）。他在埃塞俄比亚出生。他成年后带着所罗门给他的戒指前往耶路撒冷。所罗门认出了他，并给予了墨涅利克祝福。墨涅利克随后回家，他
off in great honor. The firstborn sons of the elders of Israel accompany him as his escort. But unknown to Manalik, his Ethiopian followers have removed the Ark of the Covenant from the temple. And the moment this happens in Jerusalem, dogs start howling, asses start braying, people start bursting into tears, even though they don't know why they're weeping. And Solomon, who is famous as the wisest man in the world, he twigs that something wrong has happened.
带着极大的荣誉出发了。以色列长老的长子们作为随从护送他。但墨涅利克不知道的是，他的埃塞俄比亚随从已经把约柜从圣殿里偷走了。就在耶路撒冷发生这件事的那一刻，狗开始狂叫，驴开始嘶鸣，人们开始放声大哭，尽管他们不知道自己为什么在哭泣。而作为世界上最聪明的人而闻名的所罗门，他察觉到出事了。
You know, the evidence is stacking up, all these braying donkeys and so on. And so he goes to the Holy of Holies. He realizes the Ark is gone, understands that Menelik has probably taken it, tries to stop Menelik. But at this point, the Archangel Michael intervenes and he scoops up the Ark, Menelik and his entire company, and he takes them to Ethiopia via Egypt before Solomon can even leave the Holy Land. And Solomon is so upset by this that he basically goes mad and starts worshipping idols. And this is very bad form.
你知道，证据越来越确凿，所有这些驴叫声等等。于是他前往至圣所。他发现约柜不见了，明白墨涅利克可能已经把它拿走了，并试图阻止墨涅利克。但就在这时，大天使米迦勒（Archangel Michael）介入了，他带着约柜、墨涅利克和他的整个随从队伍腾空而起，经由埃及将他们带到了埃塞俄比亚，甚至在所罗门离开圣地之前就到了。所罗门对此感到非常沮丧，以至于他基本上气疯了，开始崇拜偶像。这真是太糟糕的表现了。
Meanwhile, Menelik has arrived in a mysterious city called Deborah Makeda, and here he becomes king in succession to his mother. And because he has the Ark, he's able to defeat all his enemies. So that's the weapon of mass destruction again. This is the weapon of mass destruction again. And a prophecy is given that in due course, he will defeat the power of the king of the Romans, conquer Constantinople, and subdue the Jews. Okay. That's still running, is it, that prophecy? Because that hasn't happened yet. Right. And something else that hasn't happened is that Christ hasn't returned. And only when Christ returns will the Ark leave Ethiopia and go back to Zion, to Jerusalem. So that's the story. And it is viewed by Ethiopians as their great national epic. The idea that the Ark is in Ethiopia is taken incredibly seriously by a great line of emperors
与此同时，墨涅利克抵达了一个名为德博拉·玛姬达（Deborah Makeda）的神秘城市，并在那里继其母亲之后成为国王。因为他拥有约柜，他能够击败所有的敌人。所以这又是大规模杀伤性武器。这又是大规模杀伤性武器。并且有一个预言说，在适当的时候，他将击败罗马国王的力量，征服君士坦丁堡，并使犹太人臣服。好的。那个预言还在流传吗？因为那还没有发生。对。还有一件事没有发生，那就是基督还没有归来。只有当基督归来时，约柜才会离开埃塞俄比亚，回到锡安，回到耶路撒冷。这就是这个故事。埃塞俄比亚人将其视为他们的伟大民族史诗。约柜在埃塞俄比亚的想法被一脉相承的皇帝们极其严肃地对待——
the last of whom um hallie salassie was deposed in 1974 uh lived in bath briefly so that's kind of a fun link the ark covenant to uh it's a nice southwest english link to you for you tom and um there's a church in ethiopia at a place called axum which actually claims to house the ark even though the church itself has been destroyed and rebuilt several times and all these kind of the lion of hailey selassie going back all these emperors have been crowned there and every year you have a great celebration um in axum to mark the coming of the Ark to Ethiopia. But you may be wondering, where did this epic come from? And it's incredibly mysterious. So there's a lot of debate about when it was written. And the most popular theory is that it's written early in the 14th century,
其中的最后一位，海尔·塞拉西（Haile Selassie）于1974年被废黜，曾在巴斯（Bath）短暂居住过——所以这算是一个有趣的联系，把约柜和……对你来说这是一个很好的英格兰西南部联系，汤姆。而且，在埃塞俄比亚一个叫阿克苏姆（Axum）的地方有一座教堂，它实际上声称存放着约柜，尽管这座教堂本身已经被摧毁和重建了好几次，所有这些海尔·塞拉西的雄狮一脉相承的皇帝都在那里加冕，每年在阿克苏姆都会有一个盛大的庆祝活动，以纪念约柜来到埃塞俄比亚。但你可能在想，这部史诗是从哪里来的？这实在是极其神秘。所以关于它是什么时候写的，有很多争论。最流行的理论是它写于14世纪初，
when the dynasty that will culminate with Haile Selassie comes to power. So it's called the Solomonic dynasty because they claim legitimacy from their descent from solomon and you know the idea is that this epic is written to right to give legitimacy basically to a kind of dynasty of usurpers and uh the that reference to constantinople is a bit of a dead giveaway isn't it i mean to overthrow the power of constantinople suggests it must be medieval yeah except not early 14th century because by the early 14th century constantinople is a shadow of its former self. And also, there are no kingdoms of the Jews, whereas there is a kingdom of the Jews across the Red Sea from Ethiopia in southern Arabia in the 6th century. And this is also when Constantinople, the age of Justinian, in its heyday.
当时将以海尔·塞拉西达到顶峰的王朝开始掌权。所以它被称为所罗门王朝，因为他们声称自己的合法性来自于他们是所罗门的后裔，你知道，这个想法是，这部史诗的编写是为了……基本上是为了赋予一个篡位者王朝某种合法性，而且对君士坦丁堡的那处提及有点不打自招的意思，不是吗？我的意思是，推翻君士坦丁堡的权力表明它一定是在中世纪写的，是的，除了不可能是14世纪初，因为到了14世纪初，君士坦丁堡已经大不如前了。而且，也没有犹太人的王国，而在公元六世纪，在埃塞俄比亚对面的红海彼岸的南阿拉伯，确实存在一个犹太人的王国。这也是君士坦丁堡——查士丁尼时代的鼎盛时期。
So the other theory is that actually parts of it do come from the sixth century, which means that it's incredibly ancient. One of the other factors that suggests that there's a lamentable truth in that is that there's no mention of Islam. Ethiopia is a Christian kingdom surrounded by Muslim powers. You would think if it had been written in the 14th century, there would be some allusion to that in the prophecies, but there isn't any. So it's a kind of open question. But the issues around when this epic was written, I suppose the buried core, the thing that people would be most interested in is, well, does it preserve an authentic tradition that the Ark of the Covenant was brought to ethiopia and is there tom a um a top a top a renowned dare i say
所以另一个理论是，它的某些部分确实来自公元六世纪，这意味着它是极其古老的。另一个暗示其中包含某种无可厚非的真相的因素是，其中完全没有提到伊斯兰教。埃塞俄比亚是一个被穆斯林势力包围的基督教王国。你可能会认为，如果是写于14世纪，预言中肯定会有所暗示，但完全没有。所以这是一个悬而未决的问题。但围绕这部史诗成书时间的种种问题，我想，其核心，人们最感兴趣的东西是：好吧，它是否保留了一个真实的传统，即约柜被带到了埃塞俄比亚？汤姆，有没有一个……一个……著名的——我敢说——
archaeologist historian and an expert at uncovering the mistress of the universe with a maybe a family member who works at netflix who has strong theories about this is there such a person dominic there is so this is a very much friend of the show i think graham hancock i can't believe you described graham hancock as a friend of the show but there you go well he is but he i mean he without him we would this episode on atlantis would not have been nearly as interesting so he was the east africa correspondent for the economist so he knew ethiopia very well in 1992 he wrote a book called the sign and the seal the quest for the lost ark of the covenant and this was his kind of pivot moment from being a journalist who wrote worthy articles and books on economics and famine in East Africa to writing mad stuff about pyramids and Atlantis. And he proposed that
考古学家、历史学家，同时也是揭开世界之谜的专家，可能还有一位在Netflix工作的家庭成员，对这件事有强烈的理论？有没有这样的人，多米尼克？有的，这绝对是节目的老朋友了，我想是格雷厄姆·汉考克（Graham Hancock）。我真不敢相信你把格雷厄姆·汉考克描述为节目的老朋友，但事实就是这样。好吧，他确实是，但他……我的意思是，如果没有他，我们关于亚特兰蒂斯的这一集就不会这么有趣了。所以他曾是《经济学人》的东非通讯员，他对埃塞俄比亚非常熟悉。1992年，他写了一本书，名叫《标志与封印：追寻失落的约柜》（The Sign and the Seal: The Quest for the Lost Ark of the Covenant）。这是他职业生涯的一个转折点，从一个撰写关于东非经济和饥荒的有价值文章和书籍的记者，变成了撰写关于金字塔和亚特兰蒂斯的疯狂内容的作者。他提出
actually the Ark of the Covenant is in Ethiopia. And he says that it was removed from the temple by Jewish priests at a time when the priests felt that the kings of Judah weren't to be trusted, that it was removed to a Jewish cult center in Egypt in the 5th century BC, that it was then removed from this cult center in Egypt by Christian priests and taken to Axum in the 5th century AD. There's a hell of a lot of underreported removals taking place in this. Right, but there's more. So you mentioned the Knights Templar.
实际上约柜就在埃塞俄比亚。他说，约柜是在犹太祭司觉得犹太诸王不可信的时候被犹太祭司从圣殿中移走的，在公元前5世纪被移到了埃及的一个犹太邪教中心，然后在公元5世纪被基督教祭司从埃及的这个邪教中心移走并带到了阿克苏姆。这里面发生了大量未被充分报道的转移事件。没错，但还有更多。所以你提到了圣殿骑士团。
Yeah. Graham Hancock's theory is that the Knights Templar were searching for the Ark of the Covenant and that the Ark and the Holy Grail, which we will be coming to in our next episode. Next episode, yeah. Yeah, that's another Indiana Jones adventure, that they are basically one and the same.
是的。格雷厄姆·汉考克的理论是，圣殿骑士团一直在寻找约柜，而且约柜和我们在下一集中将要讲到的圣杯——下一集，是的。是的，那是另一个印第安纳·琼斯式的冒险——它们基本上是同一个东西。
But if they are, then we can just run this episode again, Tom. We, that's another Indiana Jones adventure that they are basically one and the same. But if they are, then we can just run this episode again, Tom. We don't need to do the extra recording. The papacy is very, very nervous that the Knights Templar might
但如果是这样的话，我们就可以直接把这一集再播一遍了，汤姆。我们……那是另一个印第安纳·琼斯式的冒险，它们基本上是同一个东西。但如果是这样的话，我们就可以直接把这一集再播一遍了，汤姆。我们不需要进行额外的录音。教皇对圣殿骑士团可能会
get hold of the Ark of the Covenant and unleash its awesome power. Yeah. So this is why they destroy the Templars in the early 14th century.
获得约柜并释放其恐怖力量感到非常非常紧张。是的，这就是为什么他们在14世纪初摧毁了圣殿骑士团。
Tom, I'm shocked that you waited to the end of the episode to bring in this tremendous story, which is almost certainly true. Of course it's true. Well, and so it's great fun. And I remember reading it and being completely convinced when I read it. I mean, it's all tremendous stuff. And you might think that it's all just harmless fun, except for the fact that for the priests in Axum who don't really speak English, don't have the internet, don't really speak english you know don't have the
汤姆，我很震惊你直到这一集的尾声才抛出这个几乎肯定是真的惊天大故事。当然这是真的。好吧，所以这真的很有趣。我记得我在读它的时候完全被说服了。我的意思是，这全部都是了不起的内容。你可能会觉得这只是一种无害的有趣消遣，除了这样一个事实：对于阿克苏姆那些不会说英语、没有互联网、
internet don't really know what's going on in the world of conspiracy theories and netflix documentaries are suddenly completely bewildered by the massive international upsurge of interest in uh the ark of the covenant and what may be kept within the uh the secret depths of the church in axa treasure hunters now descending on axum to kind of try and see if they've got the ark of the covenant is that what's happening yeah so there's um there's a very good book on the ark of the covenant um called uh surprisingly the ark of the covenant right by by two scholars called roderick grierson and stewart monroe hay and they write about it the clergy who would have spoken
不会说英语、你知道的、没有互联网、真的不知道阴谋论和Netflix纪录片的世界里发生了什么的祭司们来说，他们突然被国际上对约柜以及可能保存在阿克苏姆教堂秘密深处的东西的巨大激增的兴趣搞得彻底迷惑了。寻宝者现在涌向阿克苏姆，试图看看他们是否有约柜，是这样的吗？是的，所以有一本关于约柜的非常好的书——
openly about the great relic in Axum are now nervous of doing so, and those who will speak to old friends are often anxious that their names remain private. When Graham Hancock wrote his book, he had not intended to disrupt the lives of the Axumite clergy, but this has undoubtedly been the result. The great success of the book in addressing a readership who would otherwise know very little about Ethiopia, and whose interest in the relic at Axum was part of a general curiosity about the lost wisdom of antiquity has produced a kind of crisis." Oh, that's a shame.
出人意料地就叫《约柜》（The Ark of the Covenant）——作者是两位学者罗德里克·格里森（Roderick Grierson）和斯图亚特·门罗-海（Stuart Munro-Hay），他们写道：“那些本会公开谈论阿克苏姆伟大圣物的神职人员现在对此感到紧张，而那些愿意与老朋友交谈的人往往担心他们的名字被曝光。当年格雷厄姆·汉考克写他的书时，他并没有打算扰乱阿克苏姆神职人员的生活，但毫无疑问，这就是结果。这本书在吸引那些原本对埃塞俄比亚知之甚少、且对阿克苏姆圣物的兴趣源于对古代失落智慧普遍好奇的读者方面取得了巨大的成功，从而引发了一种危机。”噢，那太遗憾了。
So that was written before the collapse of Ethiopia back into civil war. And so, as ever, there's a kind of anxiety about what might be going on in Aksum in Ethiopia generally. And so if indeed the Ark of the Covenant is there, maybe it's in danger again. Maybe it needs an Indiana Jones to go and help the priests of Aksum out. I mean, definitely not to remove it. Now, Tom, it would be remiss of me at the end of this, as with your brilliant detective work on Hadrian and Antinous, you have to pick one about what you think happened to the Ark of the Covenant.
所以那是在埃塞俄比亚重新陷入内战之前写的。因此，和往常一样，人们对阿克苏姆以及整个埃塞俄比亚可能正在发生的事情感到某种焦虑。所以如果约柜确实在那里，也许它又处于危险之中了。也许它需要一个印第安纳·琼斯去帮助阿克苏姆的祭司们。我的意思是，绝对不是为了把它拿走。好了，汤姆，在这一集的结尾，就像你对哈德良和安提诺斯（Antinous）的出色侦探工作一样，如果不让你对你认为约柜发生了什么做出选择，那就太失职了。
Which one are you going to go for? I'm not even convinced the Ark of the Covenant existed. I think you can back project this idea that is so important in the Old Testament as we have it, this idea of a covenant between God and man, this idea that it's physically embodied in tablets of stone. Where would these tablets of stone be kept? And you can see how you might end up constructing a narrative that is drawing on various kind of Near Eastern traditions. And so maybe it's entirely fictional. If it's not fictional, I imagine that it just gets destroyed at some point.
你打算选哪一个？我甚至不确信约柜曾经存在过。我认为你可以反向推演这个在《旧金山》——也就是我们所拥有的《旧约》——中如此重要的概念，即上帝与人之间立约的概念，即它实体化为石板的概念。这些石板会被保存在哪里？你可以看出你是如何最终构建出一个借鉴了各种近东传统的叙事的。所以也许这完全是虚构的。如果它不是虚构的，我猜它在某个时刻被摧毁了。
Okay. Maybe, maybe by the Babylonians. I mean, who knows? I'm going to tell you where it is. It's in a warehouse in America, emitting a strange hum, where it was put by members of the US Army Intelligence Unit in 1936. Dominic, I thought we said no spoilers.
好的。也许……也许是被巴比伦人。谁知道呢？我要告诉你它在哪里。它在美国的一个仓库里，散发着奇异的嗡嗡声，那是1936年由美国陆军情报部门的成员放进去的。多米尼克，我以为我们说过不要剧透。
Well, that's not really much of a spoiler. Right, Tom, that was wonderful. That was a veritable tour de force. Now, we will be back on Thursday with the second half of our Indiana Jones double bill. And this time we'll be exploring the mystery of the Holy Grail. But of course, if you're a member of the Rest Is History Club, you can listen to that right now. If you're not, sadly, you won't, but you could join up at restishistorypod.com. Tom, are you as excited about the Holy Grail as you were for the Ark of
好吧，那其实算不上什么剧透。好了，汤姆，这太棒了。这真是一场精彩绝伦的演讲。我们将在周四回归，带来我们的印第安纳·琼斯两部曲的下半部分。这一次，我们将探索圣杯的神秘面纱。当然，如果你是《剩余历史》俱乐部的会员，你现在就可以收听了。如果你不是，很遗憾，你听不到，但你可以在 restishistorypod.com 加入我们。汤姆，你对圣杯的兴奋程度是否和对约柜的兴奋程度一样呢？
the Covenant? I'm even more excited. I was obsessed by the Holy Grail when I was... That is exactly the answer I was looking for. So listen now if you're a member of the Rest is History Club, and if you're not, we will see you on Thursday. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community,
契约？我更兴奋了。我小的时候就对圣杯着迷……这正是我想要的答案。所以，如果你是《历史其余部分》俱乐部的成员，现在就收听吧；如果你还不是，我们周四见。再见。拜拜。感谢收听《历史其余部分》。想要获取独家单集、抢先收听、无广告体验以及我们的聊天社区权限，
please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。这里有少量娱乐圈八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、独家单集以及抢先购买现场门票的权益，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。